check this guy out well wait for it wait
for it yep there that's Jeremy Jones on
the side of a Himalayan mountain 20,000
feet above sea level it's straight up
mischief like this that's made Jones
alleged altitude but look closer that's
a camera man who climbed up the mountain
with Jones capturing glorious 4k footage
for the snowboarding series higher TV
was a filmmaking feet like no other this
team went to some astonishing lengths
drink expeditions in Wyoming Ultra
remote Alaska and the Himalayas we're
talking 25 straight days in the field
well not actual field with all the snow
whatever you know it
the crew hiked thousands of feet up
mountains with 75 pound packs and the
weather wasn't always why should I say
ideal sure a 10-day storm one's gifted
them with eight feet of snow but that
also made for freezing cold and
nightmarish shooting conditions for
instance if they heated up the gear too
quickly they'd get fogged up lenses and
in temperatures like these batteries
didn't last nearly as long as normal add
to that the fact that the crew is
working off solar power made you know
vicious storms and college guys it's a
miracle they managed to get the stunning
footage they did and that no one ended
up injured or dead and if that's not a
sign of a successful snowboarding series
I don't know it is